they worked through the night battling a
wildfire that had spread over 8 000
hectares Spain's military emergencies
unit has been spraying water on the
flames and trying to create firewalls
strong winds here in extremadura near
the border with Portugal have made their
task harder hundreds of people from
three villages have been displaced but
local authorities say they're hopeful
better weather conditions could help
control the wildfires soon
I feel anger and sadness because many
people have lost animals land a bit of
everything to the fire it makes me sad
because after so many years working they
lose everything because a person started
the fire on purpose to me that's not
fair once the Wildfire started all the
teams should have been deployed
immediately not wait until the next day
the fire which started on Wednesday is
being blamed on arsonists Spain's
environment Minister has echoed
scientists in saying the country is
experiencing more frequent and intense
events as a result of the climate
emergency after three years of below
average rainfall Spain's already seen
multiple wildfires this year the drought
was made worse by temperatures in April
that are normally seen at the height of
Summer
last year according to the European
forest fire information system nearly
500 separate fires destroyed a record
000 hectares in Spain Nadeem Barber Al
Jazeera